[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo y la más gira a juicio en
octubre un web de la web dijo esta fecha
para decidir el futuro de la compra de
twitter la compañía quiere obligar al
multimillonario a que concrete el
acuerdo de adquisición por 44 mil
millones de dólares al que habían
llegado esto luego de que más se echará
para atrás argumentando que la red
social no ofrecía información adecuada
sobre la cantidad de cuentas falsas que
hay en su plataforma como llegaron a
estas partes a esta situación y que
podría pasar en la corte pero analizamos
en esta edición empezamos
lo que empezó como una especie de juego
se convirtió en un asunto que se
resolverá en los tribunales en 2017 y lo
más bromeó al preguntar cuánto costaba
twitter en abril de este año después de
tanto insistir la compañía aceptó
finalmente la oferta de compra del
magnate por un valor de 44 mil millones
de dólares y desde entonces generó una
serie de debates sobre cuál sería el
futuro de la plataforma en manos de
alguien como musk quien se ha opuesto a
la moderación de contenido contra
publicaciones que promueven el odio y la
desinformación insinuando que esto
atenta contra la libertad de expresión
para entonces el multimillonario ya
había anunciado una serie de reformas
para la red social que ahora podrían
nunca implementarse
pero luego empezó a sembrar dudas sobre
si su intención de comprar twitter era
genuina a mediados de mayo y lo más que
anunció que suspendía temporalmente el
acuerdo de compra hasta que la empresa
le entregara datos que demostrarán que
el número de cuentas falsas en la
plataforma las llamadas bots de spam era
realmente bajo en comparación con el
número de usuarios activos los analistas
comenzaron a especular que el argumento
además que era sólo una excusa para
retirarse del trato o que incluso estaba
intentando renegociar el acuerdo por un
precio inferior ya que el hombre más
rico del mundo se había comprometido a
pagar
54,20 dólares por acción de twitter
antes de que las acciones de las
tecnológicas fueran en caída finalmente
a principios de julio el multimillonario
tomó la decisión y se echó para atrás
argumentando que twitter se había negado
a proporcionar la información requerida
'twitter emprendió medidas legales para
obligarlo a cumplir con el acuerdo y
pidió un juicio para septiembre mientras
que el equipo de más presionaba para que
fuera a principios del próximo año
debido a la complejidad del caso
finalmente un juez de delaware fijó la
cita para octubre y en principio está
programada para que dure cinco días
durante los cuales se decidirá quién es
el responsable de la falla del acuerdo y
si alguno de los dos recibirá los mil
millones de dólares de multa por la
ruptura del trato matt o brien de la
agencia estadounidense associated press
explica cuáles serían los escenarios más
probables
y un posible resultado es que lo más que
podría tener que pagar mil millones de
dólares que es mucho menos de los 44 mil
millones que acuerdo pagar para comprar
la compañía
es el otro extremo es que el juez podría
potencialmente obligar a él o macs a
seguir adelante con el trato completo de
44 mil millones que es lo que twitter
dice que quiere pero hay muchas
posibilidades en el medio
twitter puede argumentar que ha habido
algunos daños debido a lo que sucedió y
ellos podrían buscar una cantidad mayor
que es más alta que sólo la tarifa de
ruptura de los mil millones sobre casi
word y que podrían terminar llegando a
un acuerdo si parece que eso va a
suceder y tal vez elegirán que no
quieren seguir adelante con todo el
juicio
pero qué sucedería entonces si por el
contrario la justicia le da la razón
iron mask iv encuentra que los números
proporcionados por twiter respecto a las
cuentas falsas no son verídicos danays
analista de acciones de la firma de
inversión privada web boost securities
advierte sobre las consecuencias que
tendría para la plataforma para mí el
problema es que si esto finalmente
comienza a caer en cascada y el problema
de los bots de twitter resulta ser mucho
más grande sale a la luz en los
tribunales creo que es realmente por en
tela de juicio muchas cuestiones sobre
el modelo de negocio la monetización y
otros y es por eso que desde la
perspectiva de la junta de twitter están
entre la espada y la pared y lo último
que quería necesitar era en un proceso
judicial con la persona más rica del
mundo
sea cual sea el resultado los expertos
hacen énfasis en el impacto que toda
esta fallida transacción ha generado en
twitter la empresa subraya que cada día
que pasa sus intereses se ven dañados
por las maniobras de más que en un
artículo publicado en el periódico the
new york times' se culpa al
multimillonario de dejar a twitter peor
de lo que estaba cuando dijo que la
compraría y que con cada tweet punzante
y burla pública mosca erosionado la
confianza en las empresas de las redes
sociales golpeando la moral de los
empleados asustando a los anunciantes
potenciales enfatizando sus dificultades
financieras y difundiendo información
errónea sobre cómo opera twitter
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos 24
punto com
[Música]